foreign
people ask that a lot they always want
him to be under the stage or some [__]
but he's uh he's my podcast partner and
he's also a comedian so he's doing a
show because he's trying to be a
comedian as well so uh
that's that I went and saw Seinfeld when
I was in college and somebody went
where's Kramer and he was like well he's
not real you know
little did we know he was on the age of
Laugh Factory saying the n-word but uh
that was a different time and a
different place you ever get that you
got a beautiful lady here people ever
say that to you that's your dad
what
what the [__] how old are you
how old are both of you this is blowing
my mind you look the same age no offense
and you're welcome
hold on we got a linger on this you look
like you're 38 years old how old are you
46. we gotta talk what are you eating
and moisturizing you look hot you got a
hot dad does that feel weird
wait you're a 40s how old are you
21 oh wow you look like older in a good
way like you look like mature yeah
no seriously don't you think there's an
age where looking older is still it's
like a compliment and then it like if
you say to a 13 year old girl you look
like you're 25. she'll be like
that sounded weird I'm not I'm not doing
that that's not that's not something I'm
doing I'm just saying like I have an I
have a niece and I say to her
weird all right
this is you guys taking this to a weird
place
it's on you I've said nothing weird it's
actually troubling your reaction to this
Jesus Christ get it together Wisconsin
get your heads out of the gutter you
weirdos so anyways I was making out with
my niece and I said to her you're doing
good buddy yeah it's like this
[Music]
you got it you picked them I don't know
somebody picked them
you think Arizona did
Trump loves telling a girl he wouldn't
[__]
that was my favorite part he wasn't even
talking to the interviewer yeah he's
like what did you say about that other
girl yeah I didn't do it
you either [__] you're not getting
there you get nothing she was a fine I
love that [__] because if you win again
do you think he can win again yeah he
can win again I don't know if he will
raise your hand you voted for Trump
somebody yelled over there who voted
there you go they got right there you
gonna vote for him again if he runs yeah
what do you love about him the most
[Music]
he's fun what if we just had him doing
like football on Sundays like just
announce the game this guy's mixed so
homes I like them but he's mixed
he throws like a black runs like a white
he's mixed
oh no those guys that's what I know I'm
about to go on when when equipment
starts
all right you said well
no that's just that's just a screw job
I'm about to leave
because I've been up here for over an
hour now I'm talking to y'all soon
um like some people some people like oh
you gonna leave with a big joke I was
like man you know how crazy that is like
it's like it's like okay so you get off
at five right
[Applause]
so at five o'clock
because most people at 4 45 they've been
shut down
all on different floors mess with other
people what's up what you doing up here
man I'm just riding the clock right now
baby I'm gonna go about here what was
the question the worst hookup I got a
good one so this happened this happened
like probably close to a decade ago I
had a breakup and I was crushed and I
met a girl online whatever and we we uh
we hooked up we made out a little bit on
the day and then I never heard from her
again I remember I kissed her it was
like a cold New York winter and I kissed
her and as I let her go I was hammered I
let her go and she goes oh my and I go
she goes I didn't expect that and I was
so drunk I go you better expect it and I
never heard from her again and
rightfully so but here's where it gets
real bad three months later I'm at lunch
with my mom and dad I get a text out of
the blue she goes where are you I said
I'm in Union Square uh what's up she
goes I want to see you when I want to
get freaky with you
oh
yeah so I excused myself from lunch with
my parents obviously look at this seems
important and I'm like hey what's up and
she goes uh yeah it's like I've had a
bad week at work I want to [__] and I
was going all right all right so I go
back to the table my mom I was like Mom
I gotta leave this audition just came up
and uh I lied to my mother's face in
pursuit of a [__] but uh it's not a
high point in my life so I go to a place
and it's like shady it's a different
apartment than I walked her back to and
on the first day but it's like New York
you're like people sublet right so I go
to a place she comes it's like a luxury
building in Brooklyn she comes
downstairs she looks beautiful and uh I
said let's go get a drink and she goes I
have scotch upstairs so this is all real
[__] by the way we go into her apartment
all the only thing in the apartment is a
bottle of scotch and a couch
she sounds like a top
so we start making out she starts
sucking my dick and then she stops and
she goes I sure hope my roommate doesn't
catch us and I was like yeah me too and
then
and then we uh she's like I actually
actually want him to catch us and I was
like what that's when I should have left
uh
unfortunately I was on my dick uh
so we so she's I said let's just go to
your bedroom she goes okay we go to a
bedroom start sucking again he walks in
he's I've been set up this is by far the
worst hookup Story of My Life by the way
he's just staring at me and she's
sucking my dick in a moment of panic I
just turned him I was like can I help
you
can I get you anything he's like are we
gonna do this I was like what what are
you talking about and he goes her and I
was like there's been a misunderstanding
and he goes you're either in or you're
out I was like is this Ocean's 11 what
the hell are you talking about I'm out
so he said the door's that way and I was
just like I don't know all right I'm
gonna go They're Gonna rob me I don't
know what's happening your mind plays
tricks on you so I I kind of don't even
pull my pants all the way by like hobble
out I grab my backpack and I uh Pokemon
trainer
but I just I remember walking around
McCarron park in Brooklyn I was like I
want to kill myself and as I hit my
absolute lowest my mom called to see how
the audition went
how'd you meet your beautiful wife
Connor
Bumble I hate that one that's what the
women message first I'm always like I
want to sit my dick pic no
foreign
you've just always been a big dude did
you play football no you didn't you did
nothing with that Bobby
spitting God's face
it's unbelievable I'm about chasing a
goddamn basketball pipe dream and you're
walking around with that body not doing
a goddamn thing
I'm relegated to division three junior
college basketball
but God could have swapped us bodies
he looks like a Powerhouse
but quite sensual
like the type of guy that just was like
damn are you okay
I just want to make sure you're
comfortable but good
the other way
there's another big
brother oh yeah dude whatever you you
definitely did you play sports I don't
know why I said definitely
yeah a crazy racial blind spots
well sir clearly
[Laughter]
oh
In fairness I said it to the crackeriest
Cracker
right up top but I went straight to
Michael Clark Duncan
I was like let's walk a Green Mile in
their shoes
[Music]
did you play sports or are you just like
a dynamic Knitter
that was too close what am I doing
I've been I was trying to think of like
the most feminine [__] you could do and
then I'd throw that out there
hey what's up that's great timing is
this a sitcom
right here I wrote that
these have a sixth sense were you like
taking a [__] you're like you're gonna
wrap up he's gonna read my name
tattoos
where did you come from I feel like you
parachuted into the game
Daniel's here
you really do it's a good entrance
so okay why did you write bad bad
tattoos tattoos
I mean handwriting is too small no it
was good you need to leave him
we got a Jonah Hill over here guys
too small the comment's gonna be
embarrassed by you
no people have been talking about I
don't want to be my mom told me about it
too
Brad you can't be with a girl with tiny
handwriting okay you're right mom I'll
write it bigger at the comedy show
yeah this is like the written version of
mansplaining
[Applause]
it's hilarious I almost feel like she
was writing it and you're just like a
disappointed teacher watching me go down
like
I'm gonna have to jump in again
fix your mess
like I always do there's a big Sharpie
and he goes bad tattoo you're welcome
comic with bad eyes poor guys trying to
get a salad to the table
which one of you spinach eaters wants it
mother
it's probably gonna be a lesbian
Munch all day though
[Applause]
I had lesbians in the hotel room next to
me the other night I thought there was
octopuses and explorers just going up
and down the Walls
oh
not the lesbian this is Star Trek
very close
nerds fun
did you just Pat him on the head
I did it once it's not happening again
I'm gonna help this time though I want
to help
let me help
who's this Allen who's the [__] salad
here
salad
oh this is the worst
this is the worst Cheesecake Factory
I've ever been to
that guy doesn't even work here
he just wants to watch a show so he
grabs the salad well we don't even sell
a salad it looked like meant when you
were a youth pastor and wait for her to
turn 18.
how did you mean
at College both in college
what college
that doesn't sound real
I feel like you just insulted me in
second grade BYU
where's that Pennsylvania
I'm so close
what part of Utah
Pro that's where the P comes from yeah
somebody's cracking themselves
where are you laughing at I'll be real
it's because I'm shocked that they met
at College because like don't try to
sign contracts
it's weird that you know that
it's weird that nobody was talking to
you and then you would volunteered that
information and Cyclone dudes are like
hey man the age of consent in Alabama is
14.
that's not the flex you think it is
like I know I signed it I violated it
now I'm in jail dawg I can't live
nowhere near School
[Applause]
you see me on TV To Catch a Predator
season 12.
that's right I was the one who showed up
and continued to eat the peace
wait I want to know how do you know
about that
first of all I didn't even know there
was a contract that said you got to sign
it and say you're not gonna why use that
it's not a contract okay I feel like
we're all on an episode of Better Call
Saul right now
your honor my client has no [__] if
I'd like to start the bathroom I'm not
[__] without pen and paper baby
tell me what it is break it down I'm a
Jets fan oh my God
every time I ask this man a question I
get 12 more questions how do you guys
know each other
spreads from when probably like five
years ago six years ago nice what was
the what was the meat cute
huh card meat something like that cars
car me you show your guy's whole lives
are dictated by cars
a car meets you guys just hanging out
like check out other dude's cars do you
race yeah oh yeah dude illegal racing
the hell yeah dude
that's interesting that Buffalo has a
race because it's like you'd think you
can't be that fat in race cars
that's awesome dude if you raise your
skinny guys you have to put like a
sandbag in it
huh he doesn't have a passenger that's
awesome
I love fat racing that's every car is
going 45 miles an hour
respected the car meet you guys ever
hear anything shut up
you guys ever do like anything illegal
with fast cars
allegedly you can't go fast no no like
my car couldn't go fast oh your car so
you asked for your your an aspiring
illegal car racer yeah
like in the movie The Fast and Furious
you're one of those guys behind Ja Rule
watching them get ready to race all
right nice I got you that's great I had
no idea there was a thriving car meat
culture oh you sir you look fitted you
look fit you look great
okay
are you with your girlfriend
almost oh is this like a first date
okay cool let me take control uh
I hear a very intimidating accent where
are you from
Moscow okay cool
okay yeah we've all watched the news
relax
yes if he wasn't so muscular I would
bring it up but you know what I mean
well thank you for coming to the show
I'm gonna move on because it seems
really kind of a
point of any comedy over there
um
thank you
really
an assassin in the front all right
that's beautiful this is It's a budding
romance maybe I'll talk to the woman are
you also from Moscow oh okay where are
you from
Persian from Iran okay
fun couple all right
you
[Applause]
Yuri okay
uh
you two could really cause some [__]
globally honestly that's good Lord
anyone who's not in the news
um
Jesus Christ I feel like Wolf Blitzer
it's great that you guys are together we
can contain all that all right
well this is my point and may I say it's
beautiful the budding romance or the
whatever the alliance whatever
um
how are you is that your boyfriend
first date
yeah that's more remarkable than any of
my material
um where did you guys meet and let's try
not to bring in any type of global
conflict what um
hey YouTube
where did you meet sir High School oh he
might be a teacher what the [__]
[Laughter]
I said nothing from the news
it's like is it like something to be
cool now like how old are you oh 24 so
you're young enough do you like it were
you victimized today by something but
did Mr Potato Head victimized you what
did you do with Mr Potato Head show me a
Mr Potato Head where you touched it yeah
so it's like young kids like you it's
like you know everybody is like you grow
up maybe not you but because you know
you look actually look like you know you
probably weren't you had a pretty decent
life you look like what's your name
Trevor or Trent or some [__] what is it
it's Connor get the [__] out
[Applause]
no dude I don't feel bad for anything it
could have been victimized you could
have been burglarized today I don't care
you deserved it Connor being a parent is
one of those things that's like you know
who is Kid you guys have you don't have
kids right God forbid Connor no way you
know what I feel like I don't have kids
I have Bitcoin
kids are crypto
are you investing in the future I feel
like during that time does he have
Bitcoin he [__] done shut up I know
you do you're like it's time to sell
are you watching crypto I got a new
Timber if you're gonna [__] DM me
about crypto tips you piece of [__] if
you don't change your name to
cryptoconnor I won't follow you back
does my hair look crazy like I feel it I
feel it you know do you ever feel like
well you're a guy it's a little
uncomfortable what do you mean
looking at it are you serious right now
I I hope you are because this is being
taped and I do I'm amazing at crowd work
so are you being serious
you what
talk to me
if it were up to you you'd like it
different
are you with a woman at the show right
now no
are you with him
are you gay is what I'm trying to find
out you're not gay you're married to who
a girl
with different hair but you're
commenting on my hair as a straight man
that you would like a different
are you sure
you're comfortable in a relationship
with a girl don't cut in right now
be quiet
you can and you're talking with your
hands like this
I could sing and you're talking over me
with a little bit of a list let's get
into this what do you do for a living
don't think about it answer me because
you're you're very secure as a white man
right now so don't back down answer me
what do you do for a living
salesperson what do you sell
whatever whatever you're backing down
talk to me I'm a woman talk to me like
you talk to women talk to me don't back
down now
Financial what
don't don't back down you're good at
sales you're a Salesman now you're
putting your arm this is [__] amazing
you're putting your arm around him and
rubbing his breasts
to make him feel comfortable this is
amazing what's happening with you two
straight men
you feel for him right now you're
comforting you're comforting him because
he's in a conversation with a woman
I love what's happening right now you
can't even continue this you feel
uncomfortable I I don't
I'm going at all I feel very comfortable
now you know what it feels like
now I do win I know because I've been
doing this for 23 years it's good to be
here
it was uh
uh we've been traveling my
I'm like oh hello oh I say Samuel are
You My Mother holy [__]
you're that old how old are you
a little bit up already
I look great then none of this is adding
up here right
and what does he do
garage doors
had to get in that one
it's hard no I didn't ask for being
married to her is like I asked what
garage doors
I'm just gonna get happy I thought we're
gonna have a fun night but that does
explain a lot though honestly but
you know what I
I'm funny half the time you're annoying
all the time so
yeah well you struck me as a dead bad
girl
how long have you been dating
[Music]
there wasn't footage of that I would
tell everybody that it did fit okay
let me see it one more time
maybe this hand which hand does it go on
nope you're tiny this is a really good
ring though really nice
this is a good rig I hate rich but
that's a good one oh nice and how did
you guys meet
were you working there you're both
working there trash nice
[Applause]
it's the trashiest way to meet somebody
were you working there
you were you hated it why was he the fun
goofy guy always coming up behind you
grabbing your boat
oh this is it again
every fall food can't pull that [__] off
you can pick a woman
[Music]
[Applause]
where you know them from
this is High School
no just now they emulated all those
years was it awesome when it finally
happens you're like oh dude I can't
believe my addiction Heather from 50
years
what's that now
are we talking about the same thing
right now sir
nicotine for what for the poops
nicotine helps your poops
how so
what's that now
it leaves
strict by the way do you always talk in
this broken speech pattern
it please
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean I don't even know what condition
a doctor would diagnose with what you
are
it's not [__] it's not Tourette's
[Music]
[Applause]
even Disney villains would be like this
guy's [__] up
I was gonna steal some puppies but he's
got some sort of weird Asperger
cheeseburger thing
[Laughter]
um
[Applause]
who's married to that
oh gross
oh God
he probably falls asleep going down on
her
and she's like grabs his head back to
that now I like how you won't look at me
you just looking straight ahead of that
lady
dude that's a creep stare you guys you
have a happy pumpkin
you were lost in it wow all right oh I
know what it is you're just lit up drunk
that's that's why that's not far away
stairs
the way you even looked at me you look
like it like you're a blind guy
listening you're like what
a blind guys always point with their
ears like I think he's over there
thank you
I'm not feeling good nothing
you're blind drunk that's [__] sick
you're a surgeon
shut up
I mean this is what doctors say we
sacrifice so much we spent our 20s to go
to med school and that's why we deserve
whatever but you didn't say that's not a
sacrifice that's a bet
you bet 200 to 400 000 in school so you
bet that after you graduated people
would pay you an exorbitant amount of
money and then a few women clap and
consider your hero
what's your name orthopedic
cash
[Applause]
sometimes the stars align like
this is one of these life lessons that I
feel like you should learn all day this
weekend
when the stars are aligning you have to
recognize when the stars are aligning
for you and this is one of those moments
we have no orthopedic surgeon named Cash
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out